regardez mantois la rivière ca c'est
pourquoi tu vois
ça bouge un peu tout ça donc on va
tomber près de là
gaza
entre étudiants justement à dorothée
sera salée s'installer à l'hôtel être le
rassembleur capco
je pense qu'on va voler jusqu'à 8h30 par
le soleil va pas trop bouger les doigts
quand même un gros noah ce qui arrive
dans une heure et demie on les cuit
on tient une heure
c'est un petit anneau peut-être avec la
rivière les regrets refuge sur la
rivière faisait pas honneur aux puces ou
pas de foncer dans les villages temps
après sur le jeu portera lé temps de le
faire trop tard maintenant cette voie là
dessus pour un peu la droite vers la
gauche c'est un joli ça va être
comme ça
dix ans
tous les trajets on verra plus les îlots
j'attends qu'on est passé des lots pour
inviter les fenêtres avant votre départ
à 60 ans avant de l'état d'écouter ok
c'est bon
puisque la rivière est directement sur
le sol
voilà bon pas trop
je peux cependant
pas un peu de travers avant bon
dommage alors la peau contre la pression
est sur la
voie qui pourrait inclure la gauche quoi
qui pique envers la cause de la lysine
l'avant ce qui fâche
non ce n'est pas beau ça
non
ses flancs usine on vendra pas peu plus
gros plan sur les îles ou pas